let's take a look at the first page of
your screenplay for the last showing
the page one analysis was this an
original spec script
or a work for hire yeah this is the
original spec
uh the script and just one of those
ideas i had
based on a experience i had of being
locked in a multiplex cinema
and realizing how eerie and strange and
how brilliant it would be to set a
horror film in there
i didn't really set out to make a horror
film and the opening
was originally very very different um
but um yeah but in the shooting script
obviously it's it's uh
it's very different to what i originally
wrote in one of the early drafts
how was the opening different in in the
earlier draft
it was actually some sales feedback um
that i wanted to make a film that
started in the cinema and ended in the
cinema and that's it there was no
outside world
there was no real backstory there was no
you know i wanted you to feel trapped
and part of that
that your whole world of the film was
that multiplex cinema
and i kind of stopped my guns for quite
a long time with that
and actually it was a sales agent that
said
well for the trailer can we have some
shots of them walking
in london past london bridge because it
helps the trailer look good it makes it
feel like it's a higher budget and
that's a bit like
come on is that really what we're gonna
do like i understand
like how on the trailer you want to make
it to look big and expensive and have
scale
but i was hoping that and this obviously
before i shot the film so
they hadn't visualized kind of how
cinematic the
film the inside of the cinema is going
to be so i think they were nervous about
um only having the film set in the
cinema
so instead of just writing that scene i
thought actually this is a really good
opportunity to tell some visual
storytelling and establish
these two very or three very different
characters
and their very different experiences
that help set up
the film and probably in a way that
actually
works better than i originally intended
um it allowed me to cut some of the
expedition out of maybe dialogue later
on and tell it more visually because
i let go of that little idea of only
being in the cinema and
and and it actually opened up a few
opportunities to
tell a story that um put these
two worlds these two very different
worlds at odds with each other
and kind of have fun with the contrast
of that um
because you have this um
projectionist character that's very
careful very meticulous
very much about detail very much about
control
and it's you know the film is about
you know one you know one of the things
about a comment on the change in
multiplex cinemas how
things have become digital and and how
the art of projection
of projecting film has been lost for you
know dcps and that
a lot of these life-long projectionists
that have done it and their fathers have
done it and their father's files have
done it you know
suddenly they're you know they're made
extinct you know
um and that's for to put your life's
work into something and then have it
taken away from you
in a very unfair way um
what this new opening allowed you to see
that descend
you know and let's see him lose the
control that he has in his world
of the projectionist booth and then be
retrained by a young person on a till
and
be forced to wear a silly hat and a you
know and
be basically degraded um
as a character um to kind of set up why
he does the things he does in the film
and to contrast that was
i wanted there to be a real connection
between
our two uh younger characters because
they're you know they're dating
there needs to be emotional stakes
between them in terms of
he needs to really be into her in order
to do the things that he does
so it was it was a good opportunity to
see
how they first met and um tell a kind of
a little love story uh maybe more like a
commercial would
you know without dialogue um in a more
visual ways kind of
help set up how they met and where we
find them
you know when the film begins and then
also have fun with
the fact that um you know i knew at this
point it was going to be
freddy krueger so um
you know and and it was a psychological
thriller so
we could we could have a halloween party
and have
and and play with the expectations of
what horror characters are
and and stuff as a little nod to the
audience of like i know we have a horror
legend
it kind of you know it's sort of like
breaking the ice i don't know somewhat
um but also just having fun with that
status he has as a kind of horror legend
so
i turned what actually was a really
silly
sales note into something that i
actually think made the film better and
i'm actually really proud of the opening
of the film
uh because i think there's no dialogue
for like five minutes or something
um so um so the visual side of me
obviously enjoyed doing that you cut
back and forth between locations
seven times on the first page can you
talk about the pacing of the opening
yeah i um it was a funny one because
as someone that really likes white space
um it's quite a dense
first page um and
i i tried to be economical um
and i mean i wrote this you know a
number of years ago now so i feel like
i've
whether i'd maybe write it differently
um
now just to be um
more again more maybe more about the
visual flow as opposed to the kind of
shooting script order of what it is but
again it you know that first page is is
trying to set up the film
set up the characters and and that
contrast between locations
so we have the you know splicing a film
the art and the beauty of lacing up a
film and projection
with kids getting drunk
vomiting over balconies partying
you know these and you know
these worlds are going to collide at
some point
and that's what the intercutting is
doing
is to kind of set that montage up
it's one of those that's maybe
more frustrating on the page because it
feels
a little bit dense because you're having
to change headers a lot
which actually when you see it when it's
shot which is actually all slow-mo and
with music
and it's it's it's it it flows a lot
more visually than it would on a page
um so i think that's always a
frustration
personally to try and alleviate the kind
of
the headers and the and the the backbone
of scripts that can sometimes get in the
way of the flow
what are the big questions we as an
audience would have after reading the
first page
i think you would want to know or i
would hope you would want to know
um well firstly that these these are two
different
types of people you know not only from
age but in terms of
outlook in terms of experience you know
and hopefully there's a tension in
that juxtaposition of like how are these
things going to come together
how are these things going to intertwine
and when they do intertwine
we know not quite sure how why or when
they're going to meet
when they do meet we've got all of this
history
you know um that is coming whether that
only takes your page or five pages
you know the there's um as an audience
you've been giving this
information and that hopefully makes
that first meeting
uh weighty and dramatic even if they're
not which actually
when eventually they meet they're
ordering popcorn
you know it's uh it's not actually that
viewing that tense on the page if you
started with that but because you know
where they came from
hopefully you're colliding these worlds
these kind of different characters
together
so i hope that that comes across um from
the first page
and then just you know playing with the
contrast of
the art of lacing film and a projector
it's very beautiful to watch and it's
very skillful and very delicate and very
you know
and quite and very technical with
you know met a very messy carefree
young generation that doesn't care about
that
you know that doesn't care about the
detail it doesn't care about
the art form they just want to press
play you know
and they don't really care if it's 35
mil or
70 mil or anything like they just want
it to start already
you know so it's kind of hopefully
setting up that feeling as well
in the next action we meet stuart lloyd
and this could be
our protagonist and the only description
that we have of him
is that he's 53 years old and we don't
see his face
why no further description for stewart i
felt that first actually thinking back
and probably i'm quite surprised by
the fact there's no more description um
maybe i would now if i wrote it but i
think maybe at the time i was
trying to um
give the impression that what his job or
what he was doing was kind of more
important
then about how we how he was described
or what he felt about it was kind of
maybe felt like real estate on the page
that i could do without because what he
was doing was more important and the way
he was doing it said more about
him as opposed to what he was wearing or
whether he had a moustache or
you know or like he reminded you of x
you know
um i think uh i think that was
probably what i was getting at when it
was when i was writing it
what was the overall atmosphere you were
looking to build on the first page
i think the overall atmosphere was
probably intrigue i just wanted people
to be intrigued by
maybe firstly seeing something that
maybe
a lot of people don't see you know like
lacing projectors and
the whole um art
and care and attention that goes into
you watching a film because
no you know the whole one of the whole
point of the film is no one ever really
looks behind them
no one looks up and obviously it's a
horror trope look behind you
but like you know no one looks up at
that projectionist booth and thinks
there's a person in there that has laced
this film that is watching this film
that has checked the film that knows
that cares about
turning down the lighting and you know
and the sound
and is there as the koi control so you
can have the experience
and not have to worry about that anymore
um and that's now gone
in most you know theaters multiplexes
that's now gone
um so if so it was nice to
um capture that and and funnily enough
just as a little side note we
the cinema we were shooting in in the
time it took for us to wreck it
and then shoot the film got rid of all
of its 35 ml projectors
so this is all happening as we were
filming it um so we had to go somewhere
else to shoot that
which had one so like it's just our
imitating life
it would take heart a little bit uh in
in that in that kind of thing
so yeah i want the intrigue and also to
um
maybe set up two stalls for
um the audience to
relate to uh either stuart as the
projectionist or
to the younger characters um as you know
and and whether that's age or experience
or whether you like them or don't like
them
you know um it would probably be
a sweeping generalization to say well
older people will relate to stuart and
younger people relate to them right but
it was the idea that there's something
in this film for everybody
um and also the idea that
you don't quite know who the bad guy is
yet you know you don't quite know
who it is and that's a big part of the
film is the idea that
the phil comments on um
what is a protagonist and what is an
antagonist and
and as the and the power of a filmmaker
you have to
edit things and change things and
manipulate things to make someone
whose intentions are good seem bad which
is exactly what stuart does to the
martin character in the film
um while he's making his film you know
he turns his good intentions into being
the bad guy
because he ultimately wants to become
the hero of his own story
even though the audience knows he's the
bad guy
but because we've set the film up like
this we
understand why okay we may not agree
with what he's doing
but we understand why he's been pushed
over the edge um
so that's obviously a lot from a first
page but
hopefully that's what this is all
building towards this is all setting up
for the audience
just as a side note do you go into
stuart's backstory at all or no you just
set him in that time and place and then
we find out the reasons why he feels
sort of obsolete
yeah i mean he comments later on
the about the change of he becomes the
kind of mouthpiece for
projectionists or kind of not all
projectionists
or murderers but like but um he
he comments on like the state of horror
for example
and i had a lot of fun writing and
directing that scene
knowing that horror icon was saying like
kids these days don't know what horror
is it's all about gore it's all about
sex it's all about violence
you know in in his day it was about what
you didn't see
and everyone's like ha ha he's freddy
krueger talking about knight reddell
street versus a saw
you know so it's kind of a it's a fun
thing for an audience you know um
hopefully not
not enough to take them out of it but
also what the film is actually about
you know is about a comment on horror
and a comment on cinema
um so that that was fun fun to write but
that comes later on in the film
this is the only real backstory we get
which is very visual about him
why he loses his job what he has to do
uh it's very demeaning i mean i think on
page two
he's sweeping out the cinema and he
finds a used condom
between the seats and it's disgusting
and we shot it
and it's horrible um and it's like the
lowest of the low
but again it's about the lack of respect
for
cinema for his art it's like
if you're finding a used condom in the
cinema nobody's caring about the the
time and attention
you know he's putting into the
projection of film so
it was kind of fun again very visual
shorthand
to try and get that feeling across how
do you feel about the amount of mystery
and intrigue
on page one i think there's a good
amount of
um mystery and intrigue i mean that's
hopefully my intention
i think there's definitely intrigue when
you watch it because it's all
shot in a kind of slightly ethereal
maybe slightly creepy
kind of way it's you know it's all kind
of tracking slow-mo
shots it's all about extended moments it
feels like
slices of time kind of extended out
longer than they should be uh and it's
trying to set up that kind of
maybe more maybe more like kind of
psychological pacing
um that that's kind of to come
so i hope there's a good amount of
intrigue that makes you turn the page
um based on what the characters are
doing
and what you might see and for that same
reason of like
wondering how these worlds collide you
know if you haven't seen the trail
obviously if you're coming into this
clean
you know you're like well how how how do
these two worlds come together
you know looking back on it now were
there any mistakes
you feel you made with page one i would
say i was surprised maybe how dense it
was
um based on i think i probably got more
confident as a writer
um in terms of
uh and i it's
it's a shooting script you know we're
looking at so obviously you've got
the headers and the um
more drawn out but i think i may have
written it
um in that way from the off words i
think now i would do
very simple headers i probably wouldn't
say interior exterior i'd probably just
say
you know cinema or seating or you know
something that kind of
helps that intrigue more that makes you
work a little bit harder and draws you
in a little bit more than
i i really i find that um
you know exterior cinema projectors
booth
night it's just so it's a drag to read
you know on a page and i think we can
get very caught up in
thinking that we need that stuff when
actually we really don't especially in a
first like in a non-shooting script
draft
you know i would say that you just strip
all that back
and just have the the
essential information that you need
people know if something's interior
exterior and if you don't
you know from what the scene is you know
like it's
if it's unclear then i'm trying to think
of an example where it wouldn't be clear
but
um you know people have a ver people are
very astute
you know reading scripts people have a
very good visual eye so
i i would probably try and make it a bit
cleaner maybe now
um maybe less words um
but uh certainly things i'm writing at
the moment you know i'm
i'm having like it's like alien style
where it's like two words line break
four words line break you know you just
kind of
you just go with it and it's actually a
lot more fun to to write
you know it feels a little bit more
poetic in a way
you